I am really excited to be here today as
we continue to evolve our special
operations forces
because I really want to hear the
thoughts and questions that this
distinguished group of both thought
leaders and practitioners and those just
in the general public that we serve um
although student General book I guess uh
the academic general public that we
serve have so I'm going to try to leave
time for questions at the end and then
happy to talk to folks in the
intervening moments and the breaks in
the breakout sessions as that's useful
as we think about zop's role in the 2022
NDS I want to start sort of towards the
end of that document to where I don't
think a lot of people start which is in
the force planning section and I'll read
you the quote but it says the Joint
Force must be shaped to ensure the
ability to respond to small scale short
duration crises without substantially
impacting high-end warfighting readiness
and the reason I start there is because
that shaping is really to us about the
continued use and the potential growth
of our special operations forces when
you think about what history shows us
when we are designing our military for
high-end Conflict at the end of the day
attrition-based Warfare does not fare
well in small-scale contingency and
crises and so that is what is in soft
DNA soft was designed in World War II to
fill that Niche and then has grown since
then and evolved its capabilities so
it's part of our heritage it's part of
our skill set we have five core missions
as we think about them in the sort of
broader terms one is contributing to
warfighting Advantage One is campaigning
then there are the the three C's counter
Veo crisis response and counterwmd those
last three are what I would put in part
of what the NDS terms other persistent
threats
Saab will continue to use its expertise
to handle those kinds of threats so that
the larger joint boards can do the first
part of the NDS to prioritize
modernizing and meeting the pacing
challenge of the PRC and dealing with
the acute threat of Russia
so when you add campaigning into CBO CR
as we say CM wmd you realize that a
fundamental role for soft is actually
also part of the underpinning of the NDS
and that is preventing strategic
distraction and I really think that's an
important point for everyone to think
about when you think about the last 20
years when we became such experts in CT
and CBO because we're so good at crisis
response but that still meant that the
larger Enterprise really focused on that
mission set and pulled us away from some
of the evolutions that we saw as the PRC
developed some of its technology as we
saw Russia becoming increasingly
aggressive
so with that understanding and also I
would say the understanding that we do
all of that
today at less than two percent
approximately 1.7 percent of dod's
budget
so to me that is exactly what we're
talking about when we say we need to
have the ability to handle those small
scale contingencies and respond to those
short duration crises without diverting
the larger Joint Force The Joint Force
can only modernize if we are successful
in preventing those strategic
distractions so that underpinning is
there
if we then look at
what we do in the Three core NDS
directed means how are we going to win
this decisive decade I want to talk a
little bit about each of those
integrated deterrence campaigning
building and doing Advantage those are
our three lines of effort under the ndis
if you think about integrated deterrence
it is again something that is I think
second nature to soft we build high
functioning cross-functional teams all
the time they are inter-agency most of
the time they involve foreign partners
and what we do with that is we try to
create strategic impact with tactical
Excellence but we also provide that
platform and that convening ability
that's something that carries into
integrated deterrence that is going to
give us options and give our national
decision makers options in this next
decade
we also
don't just convene but we enable our
interagency partners in many cases and
our foreign Partners one really
interesting example of an area where
we're trying to increase capability and
where we think there's a lot of room is
if you think about well I'll call
irregular warfare medicine
and IW Madison is about making sure that
in remote hard to reach areas there's
medical capability that creates
resiliency for a civilian population but
also for a military that may not be as
capable makes them more willing to fight
if they believe they have access to care
and it's particularly urgent and acute
care so that's a good example of where
we can enable our partners by just
training them in a very specific enabler
as well and then as you all know the
lead up to that is we provide some of
that enabling usually in sort of as
they're learning
um another example of how we bring
everything together and perform high
high functioning cross-functional teams
is a term I think many of you are
probably familiar with which is the
Triad concept and that is something that
uses agar Army Special Forces folks have
come to come up with
primarily but it applies to everybody
which is the cyberspace soft Triad and
the reason that's interesting is not
because it's actually a really different
way for soft to operate it has more to
do with the fact that people don't think
of those things together they think
they're all distinctly different right
like we're supposed to be in the desert
where there is no electricity so why
would we be talking about cyber and
space right how's that supposed to work
um and it's really because of our
placement and access so our placement
and access can enable cyber and space
operations so we allow us to go to a we
take existing capabilities bring them
together and then make them more than
some of their parts because again of our
tactical excellence in placement and
access
if you think about campaigning
this is a place where I would say we're
going a little bit back to soft's roots
in a regular Warfare and unconventional
warfare
we traditionally have helped shape the
operating environment
we provide indicators and warning for
The Joint Force and that is also feeding
into integrated deterrence as well we
create dilemmas for adversaries and this
is a really interesting place where I
think in some ways the sky's the limit
for soft because we are tailorable
scalable because we can do things at a
smaller level our ability to essentially
make Mischief globally to make our
adversaries have to look left when they
want to be staring right is infinite
it's really a matter of how much we're
willing to do and where we're willing to
do it but our adversaries are looking
globally they're not just looking at the
end opaque I'm aor and so it's really
important that we be creating dilemmas
for them both globally and in
indo-paycom and that's something that
soft is uniquely positioned to do and
that also flows a little bit into the
indicators and warning because we're
able to then get to another thing which
is help counter coercion and influence
by being present we make it harder for
adversaries to to win the day
I would say what we see big picture is
most in the world don't want to have to
make a choice
and that's okay
but what we don't want them to do is
choose the PRC way we don't want them to
give the PRC unlimited access unlimited
rights we want them to feel like they
have to at a minimum balance where
possible we want that balance to shift
to us and by being present in some cases
it doesn't take much because there is
sort of a traditional the Belgium Road
initiative things like that that
increasingly other countries see
through kind of both the costs and the
benefits right when you build roads and
buildings that are made with shoddy
concrete and they fall down three years
later maybe you should have just waited
what would probably be the full three
years for the US government to approve
any sort of project right I mean that's
that's the Dilemma but
um what most countries do and it's The
Logical choice for um what I would call
a weaker State strategy is they try to
get something from both of us
because that's what they need they need
a lot you know they see themselves as
needing a lot and they'll take from both
and they'd rather not have to choose and
again as long as we are there on the
playing field making sure we understand
when that balance would shift to our
detriment then we can keep that in
balance at a minimum and over time
hopefully get to our advantage but that
only happens if you're present and only
soft can be present in numbers
globally we are in 80 countries today
so our ability to see that coercion to
see the influence and to adjust that
balance
we are the force that's doing that
without big Mass without creating huge
new dilemmas for our host countries and
potential Partners
um the other thing that we do that I
would say is very traditional is in our
mission sense of increasing partner
resilience
resistance forces special reconnaissance
and partner dropability like those are
all classic missions that we've had from
our founding and they're ones that we're
returning to now
when we then look at enduring Advantage
I think that's where you see
um
a really exciting time for soft because
when I talk about kind of using some of
what we already know how to do going
back to Our Roots it's about The
Balancing Act and the second piece of
that is investing in our future and
investing in the now and how we
rebalance and a big piece of that is US
starting to develop and align with our a
joint concept for operating that builds
on service specific capabilities and
really highlights those but still brings
them together and I say that because I
think most of you know that over the
last two decades most off regardless of
their service we're doing fundamentally
the same mission
that's no longer the case we need
underseed to be undersea we need people
in the air to be in the air we need we
even are starting to have soft aligned
space operators and we are like the
whole spectrum is there and we need
people to be aligned to their service
and that again tactical Excellence has
to be at the highest level proficiencies
so that we can create new effects
um it is not about doing the same
Mission and we have to build as an
institution
some institutional things that we didn't
really have
before and
It's Tricky I would say and I think
those of you who are operators can speak
to this but
when you're doing sort of this a huge
number of reps and sets on the same
Mission passing tactical knowledge to
the next unit is fairly easy
you know this unit comes off the field
here's what we learned here's the new
state of play off to the next unit
handoff and it keeps getting better and
better and better
when you're doing a wide array of
different missions in different domains
and bringing multi-domains together that
learning process has to become more
systemic it has to become more
institutionalized and thoughtful and it
still has to somehow be easy and that's
that's probably the hardest part of this
um and so we are looking at
really interesting Technologies to try
to help us with machine learning and Ai
and how to enable the human even more
because we have to do it not just for
the Tactical Excellence but so that
operationally we're learning in these
different spaces when there might be a
gap of a year between when you run one
kind of operation to do the next or
maybe two years
um we might have to do five other
different types of operations in between
and the same force will be asked to do
very different things and that's hard
obviously I mean tactical proficiency
partly comes from practice and so that's
going to be a balancing act as we move
into this new time frame where we have a
really unique array of missions we think
that we're going to be presented with
because again we're scalable we're
tailorable we can do something that
gives our national leadership options
that they would not otherwise have and
we can create dilemmas that might
otherwise be obvious
um who the the the creator of that
dilemma is and that's a goal of ours uh
every time we can do it so we are
doing this in different ways one way
that we're trying to uh strengthen the
institution is we are really focusing on
something that the deputy secretary is
very eager for us to do which is really
build our analytics and decision tools
and that sounds really boring and wonky
and I know that it kind of is but it's
vital I mean AI machine learning don't
get too much if you're if you're
learning you know how to tie your shoe
and you already know how to do that like
that's that's not really helpful we need
to learn how to do the things that we
don't do well today or learn where we
thought we were good and it turns out we
weren't having the impact we thought we
were so it's both about metrics and
analytics and improving our decision
tools we are investing a lot in
defendable repeatable analytics and
decision tools now as a soft Enterprise
and that's an exciting place with
wargaming bringing soft into
um the big service war games and many of
you are familiar with I think the
challenge that we face which is most War
gaming starts at phase three so if our
entire strategy rests on a concept of
deterring which means we didn't have the
conflict right
um once we're at stage three we're in
the conflict where we have to Prevail uh
we kind of lost we we failed in most of
our strategy at that point um our goal
is obviously to win in the prevent piece
but when it comes to Prevail
um
you only Prevail if you've created some
asymmetric advantages going in and
that's where soft can help that's where
we can create again not just dilemmas
but now advantages for our side The
Joint Force needs some of these key
asymmetric advantages in zava's position
to build those building blocks that will
give them that
um but it's not going to be easy and
it's it's challenging as the entire
National Security community in apparatus
grapples with
what does it mean
to intentionally compete and try to
avoid the conflict
how much do we devote to those lines of
effort and what is what is that the
shape of that that's an entire
interagency effort it's an entire
National effort to be honest
um and I think we're still finding our
way a little bit there and so that is
one of our challenges because versaf to
plug in
you know we plug in kind of again in
phases sort of zero to two if you will
once the shooting starts we have a role
and history is shown again no war goes
off without soft ending up having to go
in
um and and create some of those key
advantages key intelligence
key strategic moments but uh but our
focus is really on everything that
happens before and building that into
the the war games that we're doing is
also pushing the Joint Force to think
more seriously about what Beyond
presence and a credible military force
option they bring to the table in
prevent
um and it's it's it's
again it's a challenge
um
so the other thing is as we look at
Innovation and Bill's going to talk
about this a lot more than I need to so
I won't go too far in it but there's
some really exciting Innovation besides
AI machine learning um and kind of how
we use data and you know we have a lot
of things
um the commander likes to talk about uh
all of our next we have ISR next we have
next-gen Mobility I think there's a few
more next we have a lot of necks and
that again just reflects the fact that
we all see that where we are today is
not where we have to be this is the
decisive decade so we have to invest
smartly across the Spectrum and probably
the area that I personally am most
interested in and pushing us out but
that we're all doing it together as an
Enterprise is the cognitive domain I
think there is so much work we can do
there as we think about this whole
spectrum of the cognitive domain it's
both about what we do to enhance our
performance as the elite performers you
know we're sort of we think of soft
almost as your Elite you know pro
athlete how do you enhance that
performance by using the cognitive
domain but then how do you apply that
and how do you
disable dismantle decrement the
adversary's performance how do you get
in the adversary's decision Loop that's
classic you know oodle Loop Theory
that's not not rocket science but it's a
new enemy how are we looking at that
adversary and understanding their
decision processes
if you look around Academia today I
would say there's at least 20 different
theories of the case for how the PRC
likes to make decisions
which one's right I don't know but I am
worried that we as an Enterprise have
not been able to model or really
simulate enough of those options to
start to refine our understanding of the
dynamic that we have to be at where we
test and we come back and see what did
they do what didn't they do we're still
very early in those phases and I think
that is a real challenge for us so again
I'll let
um Bill talk more about the specific
Innovation but it is an exciting area
where I think we believe we can enable
our humans and you know
from the top to the bottom I think the
one thing I can say about the soft
community and Enterprise is we all
believe the human is far more important
than the hardware or the enabling Tech
it's about the Innovative use of that
that human puts that to or how you
enable that human to be more effective
um but science is really moving rapidly
and if we can harness that and focus it
I think we have tremendous opportunities
so again I'll just go back to where I
started which is
um we are
evolving once again as zov to meet the
nation's challenges I think it starts
with our tactical Excellence leading to
strategic impact and the first step in
that for us is that underpinning to the
NDS which is preventing the street of
distractions of The Joint Force can
modernize so that they can mobilize the
way they need to but it's also in doing
our core missions and going back to Our
Roots across those three lines of effort
the NDS demands of us and with that I'll
take questions
that I want to ask questions please
raise your hand also want to be about
Mike respond to agreeing to be able to
project
any questions to stand up
Emma please any questions
Emma is one of our senior advisors
Professor dad from the Yale
and feel free to ask I mean you can ask
her anything you want about in terms of
how things are in DC what my office
actually does not everyone knows that I
mean whatever questions you have I'm
very open
talk you mentioned Ai and you mentioned
AI in the context of operations if they
give my ignorance but like how how would
that how does that work
yeah so I think it comes down to you
um
what we see more and more which is
information overload is one piece of it
so using AI to give you
um a more digestible set of options
and then sort of assessing some of the
likelihood of those options because
there's a piece that is Warfighter
experience but again as we go into this
new era where you're not going to have
the rep since that's on the same Mission
set it's going to be more important to
take different data sets and create the
options and get a sense of your you know
you're still going to rely on Warfighter
kind of um the thing that isn't science
uh the art but you're also going to be
informed Now by what the AI tells you
are some of your better options or some
of the opportunities it's also using the
AI in much bigger back at you know sort
of headquarters wargaming hopefully to
more effectively model and simulate and
see where we can get I think those are
probably two places I don't value build
price some other like thoughts too uh
yes ma'am I guess two things popped into
my head is uh a lot of like next
Generation ISR you talked about you know
processing all that data that uh you
know we're collecting from an ISR
perspective it's just huge amounts of
data so we definitely need more advanced
Tools in that that Arena and then the
machine learning part of it yeah and
then you know the other thing is you
know irregular work Affair sentiment
analysis that kind of thing you know for
our operators and you know in foreign
countries or you know more hostile
scenarios just having a better
understanding of the sentiment of the
the local population if you will I think
that's another example I think where AML
tools could be useful especially using
you know publicly available information
cyber tools and those kind of things so
just a couple other examples yeah and I
would say like and the other thing is um
improving kind of our maintenance of our
fleets like the there's a lot there that
we're we're actually
with industry which is advancing in that
space a lot where your sensors along
with like your we have much more
efficient models now for how to use our
even our fleets that as they get older
we're more efficiently employing them
because of AI because we're able to to
see specifically where they're broken
and not just rely on a static profile of
you know two two missions and then you
get something or you know it's not
static anymore it's more specific to the
actual aircraft or other parts of our
Fleet
um so that's another kind of big area
and then we're trying to automate it's
not just sort of sentiment analysis but
the the whole spectrum of intelligence
that we collect because again it's
overwhelming in some cases in some
opportunities to the degree that we can
start to automate pieces of that as we
particularly in areas where we're
already a little clear about the
adversary that would actually allow us
to free up humans to do some other
things so you get a smaller number of
humans who have to do that exploitation
and Analysis in some cases
yeah
good morning ma'am Sam Hussein
um representing baritone Corporation
from Washington can you just touch a
little bit more about and tell us a
little bit about the office of strategic
Capital that was just launched recently
at the Pentagon and how it's working out
as far as engaging and bridging industry
Innovation and bringing it to the
software warfighters I wish I could but
I cannot uh so I bill hopefully knows
more about that he's probably more
firmly in Bill's name yeah the only
reason I jump on that man is because
they had something called The Trusted
Capital Marketplace a couple of years
ago that they were working and uh you
know basically what it is is a uh you
know an analysis of you know venture
capitalist
you know different uh Capital sources to
feed small businesses and those kind of
things that might have capability that
that we need but definitely want to make
sure that that that that funding is
trusted you know to trying to build that
Synergy between you know the capital and
the small business to what our operators
need so that whole chain of security uh
you know is the intent of that so I
don't think that the Strategic Capital
office I haven't seen anything huge out
of that yet but I think it's the same
intent there's not much of an answer so
it's a little bit nascent but that's the
same intent
we have time for one more question and
it's going to come from uh Miss Emma
Skye in the back okay
thank you good morning and thank you for
coming
you mentioned cognitive cognitive
ability
so my question is you know you come to
University like Yale
how are you going to attract the
brightest and best students in the
country to want to pursue a career in
the military let alone Special Forces
so
challenge because I actually think
I think so much of what we hear
America's youth wants today and Special
Forces actually has it sort of in Spades
I would say
um so when people want
meaningful work
they want uh
in a working environment where their
bosses people care about them as a whole
person
they want to make a difference they want
to be part of a team
all of that we offer along with
Healthcare benefits everything that you
don't get in the private sector so in
our world and we've actually like really
ramped this up even um like nsw does
this amazing
um thing where I think it's every six
months now and it's only been about two
years you've been doing this but like at
every Echelon level the commander has to
meet with their formation every single
individual with themselves the chaplain
somebody else and somebody else present
to the doc everybody to literally find
out how are you doing specifically tell
me what's going on in your life how's
your family how your finances how's your
health
are you feeling okay mentally are you
stressed and then from that you get
specific referrals to whatever will help
make your life better
and there are no disciplinary or
professional sort of career consequences
that happens every six months at each
Echelon that has to happen and so that
investment in the person is something
that I hear young people craving
somebody wanting to Mentor them to grow
them to help them be more effective to
give them that support to have a
community that cares
um so I really think our storyline is
actually great and then we also in
Special Operations literally tackle the
hardest problems
right the wicked hard problems are what
we're trying to do to be the best and so
it actually I think is a little
we struggle with I guess the marketing
of it because it's very clear it's not
working at this point but I think the
story we have to tell is fantastic and
if we could tell it more effectively in
the spaces where young people are
talking and listening I think we have a
real opportunity
um now we do draw from the general force
and I will say I think the other thing
is we're talking about this in the
Pentagon how do we
modify reinvigorate revamp the contracts
we make right so if you're in the Army
and you come into the army and what you
really really love to do is sit at your
computer and do cyber operations and you
really don't like marching through the
woods you have zero interest in the
outdoors right I still want your cyber
Talent how do I build Pathways where you
can come in and out where you learn
enough and understand you can't be a
drain on the force but there's a lot of
operations we now do based here in the
US that enable our forward operators
how do we honestly admit that bring that
into the force successfully and then
grow that and so there is a challenge as
we sort of have to reimagine some of the
contracts we make with America's youth
because
there's a piece that is absolutely
always going to be about you have to be
physically fit you have to be able to
perform in high stress environments
forward but there is a growing piece of
our work that actually happens back here
where there's still stress but it is
very different you don't necessarily
need exactly the same things that I
think people think you need for the
military career to be successful and can
we also make it so that you can come in
and out three years you're in giving me
your best then you go out for three
years you learn from industry or you do
the things you like to do there but then
we can bring you back right now in some
cases a very arbitrary time limits on
that and age limits that given as we age
as a population as we're healthier and
as some of our jobs really aren't that
stressful you know people wouldn't have
to like why do we say that's the age you
can't do it anymore for the nation so I
do think there's a little bit of there's
conversations about that it's that is an
extremely hard problem I will say um
because I will also I mean no surprise
to produce the military that we've
produced over the years
taking risk when you know one thing
works is really hard because you're
putting people's lives on the line
potentially and so
big army is going to have a large hard
time reimagining this contract but they
know they have to and so they're they're
thinking about it they're talking about
it around the margins they're starting
to do it but I think that's the other
piece of it I think we have a great
story to tell but we also need our
foundational services to be able to tell
a story that's a little different to
America's youth I think
is that it and with that please join me
in bank and Desi Logan for the
presentation
[Music]
foreign